thank you all for having me this is like
my favorite meetup so that's super super
pumped to be talking about it um so yeah
um a couple caveats i'm not very good at
calculus
so i apologize in advance for all the
several people i've talked to before
this presentation are way better at me
than me so i'm sorry uh buy everywhere
all right so who am i um i work for new
york times i like writing in haskell but
i'm forced to write things like
javascript at least i don't have to
write node
i work on the interactive times news
desk which means we're the desk that
doesn't do the cool maps
with a bunch of weather and a bunch of
other fine colleagues here as well we
basically work in the newsroom with news
desks to produce interactive content um
one of the things i like i'm really into
his fashion i mean not like i don't
expose it but like i'm you know i'm
gonna do it intellectually
and so uh i i use haskell to analyze
fashion week um and breaking and to
break down collections into these like
uh minimalistic fingerprints or whatever
so that's like one of the things i use
haskell for i've also worked in the
world cup you know ghost soccer
and some other stuff
you haven't used it probably it's not
that cool but my background is i went to
college for a really profitable career
in film and analytic philosophy
but when both of those fell through
filmed because
i wasn't willing to starve and analytic
philosophy because no one was willing to
actually listen to me about it um i
decided to move into journalism where i
have the bully pulpit more or less and
computer science is an easier way to get
into journalism than actually being good
so
that's my story so this paper
now why do i love this paper this is a
rent joke for all you theater nerds
so why do i love this paper uh i love
this paper because
when you start learning about haskell
and you start doing a kind of functional
program you hear all these terms thrown
around like algebraic data types it
could just be a name that someone gave
it because they're like this is catchy
or maybe there's some algebra behind it
i didn't know and this paper kind of
explains that or kind of at least plays
on that make some new connections off of
it this paper is the one that i read
when i was first kind of getting started
in the typed programming world and it
made me start to ask myself well
what if you just consider types like
ordinary values what what's gained
what's lost can you do that and and that
kind of sparked a lot of ideas in me and
it was really exciting to me and i hope
it's exciting to y'all as well also a
little later once i found out about you
know the silver bullet that will save
the world you know uh dependent types
i i wanted to know like well why are
they cool other than like you know my
ability to write like really cool uh you
know like dsls and stuff like that right
um and this paper kind of says hey
here's a really cool meta programmatic
use you can put uh dependent types too
probably um uh it actually says that it
says well i mean in the end you'll be
like this might be cool one day but we
can't really do it right now
so uh can we do it now maybe and also i
really like it because uh uh what what
what michael bernstein said about uh
about how the best papers are the ones
that draw connections between various
kind of far-field concepts in computer
science and math and i think he used
some word like the uh like the profane
world or something like that and i think
that this this paper really does that
nicely um so so that's one there's a lot
of the reasons i love it so how do i
read it well i started i started in a
place of deep agony um the first several
times i read it i was like wait does he
look at that kind of yeah he doesn't
mean that kind of derivative um okay do
i know how to derive things still i'm
not sure um possibly
the second point was he pretty early on
like lays his bona fides on the table
you know like funk um and just saying
like uh you know i was i was exploring
these types and i realized these were
the derivation rules i learned as a
child and i was like oh my gosh he is
like light years ahead of me i i didn't
learn like i said this vision of him as
like a little small boy like
yeah so
that was intimidating but i pushed
through it um also i kept forgetting how
associativity worked in the symbolism so
i was like wait is that equal sign
grouped with that so that took me a
little while but once i you know got it
maybe i think i think i'm doing it right
it made it a lot easier and finally i
was like wait what's the fix point again
so about 50 percent of the time spent um
spent preparing this presentation i was
on like the fixed point wikipedia page
and but then it really moved from agony
to ecstasy and because i started
learning these things i started learning
like i started becoming much more uh
comfortable like what an algebraic data
type is what a fixed point is what a
zipper is and hopefully at the end of
this talk for those of you who aren't
already totally fluent in these terms
you'll be a little more comfortable with
that as well and then also i learned all
the calculus that i wish i would have
learned in college but i didn't because
i didn't take any useful classes
interestingly enough as i was reading
this paper um i got into this discussion
of like oxford brackets and denotational
semantics and i realized that the
analyte philosophers and the computer
science field developed these two
identical concepts simultaneously and
weren't entirely aware of their
connection because i had conversations
with my professors about this and i
thought that was kind of funny anyway so
first
let's
i want to start with a little background
and make sure everyone's on the same
page about types fixed points zippers
holes all these kind of things if you
already know this stuff cool just focus
on your beer
so first um
this idea of regular types algebraic
types he uses these kind of terms a lot
of the paper and what do they mean well
it's not entirely different than you
know it's not different than regular
types it's like a way of combining types
making kind of more complex types things
like that i'm just going to go through
some of the basic ones and like the
terms i'll be using for them the terms
that paper uses for them so when we see
them later you won't be like what does
that mean
so first uh we have the empty type often
written by this nice little
combination of characters underscore
pipe underscore and nothing is an
instance of the empty type there are no
empty type neither al or nothing in the
empty type there's a controversy about
whether or not haskell has a true empty
type and that's the kind of controversy
that's really fun if you know you don't
have lots of fun in your life
and and that that will often represent
by zero
cool uh unit uh we'll also represent by
one in this kind of world and units
where there's exactly one instance of a
specific kind of type like say your leaf
type in a tree or something like that uh
or maybe your empty list type in a list
constructor we all good so far make all
sounds awesome um one one note uh
sometimes you'll see like twos and
threes and that is shorthand for like
one and one and one or something like
that so if you see a three oh it can be
one of three different things you see
two maybe you might see a two around
here it's like so think oh like booleans
right can be true or false there are two
different things it can be
cool we're all good awesome um then
there's like i don't really know what
the word for like just to type is but
basic type typey types i don't know
and and those you'll see sometimes
presented by a single variable or like
an int you know it's like a type you
have like an infinite number of them
sometimes cool whatever okay so then you
can these are like the algebraic ones
right these are like the algebra nouns
right data types um product and subtypes
now product means you have two
subtypes or whatever simultaneously so
like a pair of an 8 in a string you can
see that as a product of the int type
and the string type you have both of
them at the same time um say i have or
say if you guys are go c go guy right
structs right okay my struct has name
and date or something like that that's a
product type of name type string
probably and date type date type cool oh
all right so far and we'll represent
that by a times sign which will be
confusing because it'll look like x's
because i don't know how to format
things like the play tab
so
get ready then
sometimes some types are like
alternative types or types either types
i believe sometimes they're also
referred to as coproduct which is not
clear um so
i'll call them subtypes and you draw
them with a plus sign so this means if i
this is as half scallions will recognize
um
the maybe type constructors so either
your maybe type is nothing but or it's
just an instant integer so um this means
and this means or
we all good
awesome now there's two other types well
actually three but i won't even get into
weakening because i don't think it's
essential to understand the paper but uh
he talks about definitions um and
recursive types so
what what do i mean by this so you'll
see that if you have the paper whoa
quick show of hands who read the paper
here
good good i mean i i kind of read it too
you're in good hands
so definitions are basically like
imagine you have some kind of parametric
type like list x
if you guys have done haskell before or
functional programming or anything like
this this means a list of some x kind of
some things right so i can make like a
list of integers right and i can fill
that in by defining xbs he goes on a
field out he's using definition instead
of substitution so he doesn't have to
handle like you know unfolding things
and recursively substituting so
definition does the job because it just
kind of at the place of binding does the
replacement cool don't need to know that
just think when you see this little pipe
and then equal sign like you can kind of
replace this with this
more or less
um so you know here for instance if i
have a list of x equals either we'll go
to go over our algebras again algebraic
types either an empty list or
a product
of some x and then a list of x's if you
guys have seen
list
type signatures or whatever in a
language like hassle before this should
look really familiar ever a lot of
people have probably seen this right so
then i could say well maybe abusing this
formalism a little i'll define x to the
integer right and now i'm working on
lists of integers cool
do you see this will you be like ah i
kind of know what that is yeah very good
so then what does this mean because you
see this this little there's a lot
mu x dot f
okay um what does it mean and this is
the uh as wikipedia will tell you um
this is the uh fixed point operator room
sometimes you'll see the word least
attached to it
there's a difference but i'm not gonna
get into it
so
basically a fixed point of function is
uh something you can put into the
function that comes out unchanged right
so like say my function is like double
if i put zero into that comes out it's
still zero
zero is a fixed point for the function
double
cool
um and so you can even you can you can
represent this as you know f of its
fixed point equals that fixed point
yeah can we um conflate that with unit
no it's um i mean
for example for instance undefined is a
fixed point of like almost every
function or something like that and so
that's a lot of times people will talk
about it like that but it's really what
can you pass into a function so that it
comes out on change
identity or it doesn't count
um i don't think i would call it that um
yeah everything's a fixed point there we
go that's a good example everything's a
fixed point of identity
that might make things clear anyway but
type constructors are just functions
right okay so we can have a fixed point
of a type constructor so let's take a
tight constructor like this either z you
have zero z right or you have um s of
some
x right and
i'm sure someone has seen this before
what does this kind of look like to
somebody do you want to yell it out
was it what it hasn't taken for this
maybe
it's similar to maybe it's also what
exactly success are natural numbers
right but what would we put in this x to
actually make this
uh the natural number type signature
well we put this whole thing in that um
so how do i represent that um
so for example if i say nat equals z
plus s nat you can see how it's like
recursive it's referring to itself and
that's what we will be using the fixed
point com the fixed point operator to
mean so what exactly do i mean well kind
of yeah
it's kind of this guy
you can read mu x dot f kind of as the
fixed point of f over x so why do we use
fixed point combinators well we use them
to represent recursion when like in a
lambda calculus we might not have uh let
binding so we can't refer to functions
by by their name or something like that
so uh so right here we can say okay well
i want to put this whole thing into this
x
well that's what we use this this to
represent um so again how do we make
this into natural numbers oh well this
is sorry this is the the kind of way
that this paper would formalize the
natural number type signature so imagine
i said okay well f x equals one plus x
what can i put in this x point in this x
place so that it remains unchanged well
i can put the whole thing in because
it'll essentially just keep going
further and further in so let's say i
define
that to be the fixed point of f well and
then i just do my subs so what did it
hit sorry i define that to be the fixed
point of f okay what is my definition of
that uh fix well f of the fixed point
equals the fixed point and it's turned
it around cool so then i'm going to just
substitute
fix f equals 1 plus fix f because i just
applied this to
this function 1 plus x to fix that so 1
plus
x and then i just substitute back out
into that and i say nat equals one or
you know successor of that um so
again that might be a little unclear
because who's got time for all that
theory so you can just read uh mu x on f
as the recursive type f in which we
substitute f for x's recursively uh
that's kind of how i write the paper
so
at everything after the period of five
it's not like
the one you know if you were to put
parentheses around it and go up to
yeah so this is a problem i had with
paper too like i wish i wanted like more
parentheses and things like that so like
yeah so like he'll like write this in
the paper and this means like it's like
if in like if you're writing like a
lambda or something it'd be like slash x
arrow one plus x or something like that
so it's like after there's
everything that passes in here
right
so yeah but so it's probably easier to
think of this in this way
so again like that could be the the
nap could be represented like this so
either you have the zero type or a
successor or something type and a list
of integers can represent it by either
you have the uh the empty list or you
have an integer and then another list in
integer b tree which is a wonderful like
kind of combination type that i made uh
is you know either an empty d tree or
like a leaf node rather or an integer
and two b trees
and um yeah so again if you see this guy
in paper and you're like how do i read
this i think in pretty easy way if
you're not super comfortable with fixed
points and i don't think a lot of people
are
is just to say well i kind of just
substitute this whole thing for y and
that's how i express my recursion does
that more or less make pretty much sense
um
like on a scale of like 1 to 90 if we're
somewhere around 74 like then we're
probably good so that brand there
what 90 makes sense yeah 90 makes
absolute sense like you are connor
mcbride
so now we're going to move on to zippers
and holes
yeah so
so what what are zippers
um well as the paper as as the paper
that he cites explains zippers are like
velcro for trees so moving on
so what are zippers well
you have this problem if you have
immutable if you have immutable
and the question is if your data
structure is immutable how do we get
fast access to the children and parents
that he knows right say we have this big
tree and we're like in the middle of it
and we want to be able to really quickly
immediately right go to its children or
its parents right normally the way you
do that if you had pointers or something
like that is on each node you'd store
like it can be like a linked list or
whatever you store like pointers
backwards and forwards but you can't do
that right and if
if there's some reason you can't do that
you want an immutable type uh how are
you going to do it well you'll just turn
it inside out like a return glove
which is the other way the paper
explains zippers right so it's pretty
easy um
and well they're used for some stuff but
anyway um they're often used for uh one
example that comes up i think on the
haskell wiki is like zippers are great
to implement mazes
um
which i think uh
so you can use zippers to kind of
represent your position in a maze say
you were making like doom or something
like that um okay cool okay great
zippers are great okay how do i make it
so let's say we have this tree and in
this street for the purposes of how i
want to do b trees uh binary entries in
this sense i'm not going to worry about
like sorting or anything like that we're
just going to really worry about um and
we're going to put the values at the
branch and then leaf nodes just are
empty there's just nothing there cool so
you've probably seen something like this
before the tree is either an empty leaf
node
little tiny circles or it's a branch
node with a value and then two sub trees
we've seen this tree formally
manipulation probably before right so
how do i how do i say i wanna i'm
focused on this area right here i want
to drive a hole into my tree how do we
do that well it kind of first attempted
maybe we'll split it at the focus we'll
store the top tree and then we'll start
everything below the tree and maybe
we'll add another type called like hole
or something like that and we'll mark it
there it's not a bad idea we're actually
actually pretty close right the problem
is if i have this i can very easily get
to the children of this focus by just
you know it's the top at the top level
now but how do i get back up to its
parents
if it's really complicated it might not
be entirely trivial it wouldn't be
entirely trivial to do so this is where
the turning inside out like a return
glove comes um uh what the zipper
actually does is it stores each the left
and right children of the tree
cool but then it stores a path that you
walk down from the top of the tree so
that you can get to your focus rather
than just storing this as a tree so
basically what it does at each note it
says okay did we go to the left or the
right to get to our hole so we start at
one okay cool
got it right here then how do we get
through our hole will we take the left
path
and then what did we pass by i would
pass by this tree that's what this is
that could be an arbitrarily complicated
it would all fit right here and in here
we only have one step to get to our hole
and the reason that this is useful is
because it allows us to make a simple
you know uh immediate operation to find
the parents or the children of the
zipper and this is why it's called a
zipper because if you look at this
operation this is what it looks like to
zip up the tree and this is what it
looks to zip down the tree
it actually kind of looks as if the tree
you know your tree structure is zipping
together or unzipping because basically
all you have to do to move up is you
take the the path that you came from to
get there and then you kind of push it
onto the zipper and then everything else
becomes its children and to zip down you
just choose one of its children and then
add your current node to the path so
let's look at this in motion all right
ready for this okay
right now we're at the continent we're
at a specific node it has a child of
four and a child of five the actual node
one is two cool and the path that took
us here was one left turn passing one
and passing the well passing the one
branch and
the tree to the right is this this tree
so how do we zip down to four or five
well first we take
we
have new context
and then we uh and then we say okay well
what are the children of the thing we're
moving to because in this example we're
moving to five right so we can copy its
children right down okay cool that's
great we're in business so now we have
to write the path well this doesn't
change at all right we still had to turn
we still had to take the path to get to
where we were before to get to the next
part sweet copy it down awesome great
we're in business okay now which way did
we go from there well four was on the
left
five was on the right we went right so
okay we went right we passed by our old
value that we're at
and um and then and then the only and
the remaining part that we didn't see
was this this this uh the b4 thing so
just to go back to uh to this slide real
quick um basically what we did was we
started out right here and then to move
to this floor we just you know took
another oh sorry this is my original
tree i'm so sorry so we were here then
we went left so we just add the path
that we had on here and you know and now
now we have a four as our context so
you don't have to know how to implement
zippers to make for this paper to make
any sense you just have to know
basically their uh their rationale and
more or less
that's it a zipper but to keep it but
there's one thing you need to keep in
mind that
pretty uh come on
oh jesus oh no and there we go okay so
um so one thing you have to keep in mind
is what he talks about holes not zippers
so a zipper is just like a
hole uh one whole context rather with
that hole filled in in some way so you
say oh i'm at this point in the tree
the value is two whatever
but it's one whole context is all the
parts that aren't actually the value
that you're currently on
okay
so um what is a hole well a whole
describes given some type t that
contains x's of sort x of time x we're
looking for a type that describes a t
with one removed or you can think of it
as a t with a focus in place of one of
the exes it's a way to kind of drill
down and focus on one x cool
keep in mind that one whole contacts are
always with respect to some internal
type right that makes sense like you
can't just say what's the one whole
context of my tree well of what in your
tree
do you see any of your questions
oh you just you kind of
frown at me
um so so again oh sorry it would be like
a context of the interior type of branch
exactly
bingo exactly and that's a really good
point if we wanted to we could have one
whole context of branches or something
like that as well but we always have to
have a one whole context of a certain
type and then sorry with perspective
certain time and then finally just to
put it all together a zipper is the one
whole context of a binary tree of x's in
the in the hewitt sense right and the
value that was removed so it's not like
one old contacts and zippers are that
different it's just like a zipper has a
little extra to let you keep zipping
back up and down
okay cool
so now to get to the actual paper that's
all the pre-leg work um
uh we've warmed up we've heard about
zippers and now it's time to turn to
livenitz and his wonderful rules of
derivation or newton i don't want to
take sides
no that's a train i can't stop but
so we're going to be talking about some
derivation and it might be a little
painful but i warn you
in another world it'll be worse
so
i'm going to sketch
the childhood of conor mcgregor as or as
illustrated by this paper so he was
looking at a parasite with a triple tape
right i'm gonna tell a little story and
he wrote out his algebraic data type for
the pattern
eight times it
makes sense right
it says everyone got that to make a pair
of ins you need mint and
another
okay cool uh let's write out the type
for triple it it's it three triples
product of three ants great
ah we got some math look at that we're
cool guys cool girls so uh n times it
that's n squared
i think i can do that i mean you can't
write this in haskell or something like
that so it might not even be a real
thing you can do but okay sure
a squared
third great
okay cool so what is the what's the
context type for a pair so i want to be
able to describe a specific position in
the pair by removing something and
replacing with a hole how can i do that
when he goes well
i can write down the plate thing that
hasn't been replaced by a hole let's say
two and i can say which uh whether or
not the left or the right side was
removed okay so if i want to put a hole
right here i say okay well i removed the
left component
and the other component was two
makes sense pretty pretty much cool so
how do i do that with triples well okay
see i want to make a hole in the two
here well the other values are one and
three great and i remove the middle
value
which seems easier though okay so let's
write the type of this out okay well
this could be one of two things so two
and times and two times it
that's a fine type
let's look at this guy
well this can be one of three things
left middle right there's a three
product and product in and squared okay
so before i had n squared and now i have
2 in it for its one whole context right
previously i had n cubed and i have
three times m squared where have i seen
that oh i saw that as a child when i was
doing my derivatives and this is the
power rule right uh if for those who
didn't have such a robust childhood uh
you may you may remember the power rule
uh to take the uh derivative of
something to someone to power you take
the power make it the coefficient and
reduce the power by one i hope i haven't
gotten that wrong at least because that
that calculus rule is wrong the whole
paper's done
so
so uh this this was his kind of aha
moment this looks like the power rule to
me n squared to two times in and third
to three times n squared okay how far
can we take this because this is what
mathematicians and people like us love
to do we see is this just a coincidence
could be a coincidence so let's just
take it to its extremes okay so there's
big ideas maybe just maybe to find the
type of a context for some type t some
regular type d
um with a hole in the place of some x
remember i said all one whole contexts
are such with respect to some internal
type
take the partial derivative of t
with respect to x
now we've got a theory we've got a
theorem or something like that we've got
something we can try to prove and we can
even write in math
so
let's take a look at it from the other
way and the other we could also say um
the way that we find
the partial derivatives with respect to
x of some type is answering the question
how can we find x's
inside of ts
it's a very literal interpretation of
how can we find x's inside of a
recursive data structure um but uh so so
one what am i doing though yes
what's the importance of the poles
to the world or to this paper this is
what you're talking about so the one
whole context is so to go back um in
this boop
yeah so a one hole a context when i say
holes i'm using the two words
interchangeably one whole context and
whole and context i'm just kind of
lumping them all together so a whole
i'm really i'm just using a shorthand
for the phrase one whole context which
is some data structure with one of its
things focused on and removed
sorry that was that's my bad um yes so
um and and again the uses for holes are
spurious possibly but anyway
so let's take derivative types i know
that's why you guys are all here all
right
okay let's take some derivatives and
stuff okay first um uh what's the
partial derivative with respect to x of
zero
zero cool but now what does this mean
what does it say about types right what
does it say about types well this says
where can we find an x
in in an empty type where where x is
nowhere they're not there so they're
nowhere the answer to an empty an empty
instance is its own empty context great
okay where do we find xs in in a in a
single you know like a singleton or
something like that where can we find
x's in leaf
well uh
right what it's a whole exactly
sorry sorry i said wrong wherever we
find x's in in the type that x is right
where we find x is in int uh where can
we find it in well it is it so it's it's
itself it is one right so if you have an
int how do i get a how do i get a hole
an in hole in that in well there's only
one way to do it that's it it is there
that's the whole
it's the unit cool now what i meant to
say earlier was how do i find x's in a
type that isn't it where how can i
locate ins in string
can't i'm on javascript what
you can't find
inside of the string type or inside any
other type other than other than in just
not there so we find no x's in a y um
we'll get into the question of what
happens if that y type has x's in it but
what we have to do for the sake of this
is we have no other information we have
to assume that it's not in it he talks
about we always uh do this operation in
the place of binding
so anyway some types okay how do we find
x's in an s or a t
just intuitively without knowing any
calculus you say well i have two it's
either an s or a t how do i find x's in
that in that structure
either they're located in the s
or the t so we can find x's in s or t by
saying either we find an x and an s or
the x and a t and this is also how you
take this
as well so this context of the sum is
the sum of context right so say i can
either have a left hand or right hand
right they're like you know like
i don't know
i don't exactly know uh what this type
would be useful for me it's like some
kind of you know dirtience or cleanups
right so um if i'm looking for an int
well either i can find it in the left
and okay i have a left hole or i have a
right hole so one of two things i could
just represent that by either the result
left or right cool
so now we get to go inside a little more
difficult
the product rule this is probably where
a lot of people start you know phasing
out in
in high school tuning it out if you
unless you like calculus then it's great
you probably remember this easily so how
do i find
how do i find x's in uh s and t right
and a product of s and t well calculus
will say well we do it by finding x is
an s and then recording t or by finding
x's and t and recording s and that's
also intuitively how we do it in types
right and i even i so in the
explanations either we find that the x
in an s and then record the other team
you know because we can't just throw
that information away we have to know
what this partner was or we find the x's
and the t in the record s so let's just
consider for a second just to slow it
down a little bit where we're looking
for um we're looking for eight contexts
so some end right in a pair of in and
string now we probably immediately know
what the answer this is going to be
right because i already said well we
can't be in strings there's really only
one place we can find is but let's just
work it out in terms of the product so
we have eight times string so what this
says is to find the uh the
partial derivative of the product or to
find the context of the product what we
should do is this operation and then we
say well well
based on the rules back two slides right
the uh
we find ants and ants in exactly one
place we find hints and strings nowhere
we substitute that in and what we get is
we get one times string plus n times
zero
that anything times zero equals
anything times one equals itself so the
when we add when we actually uh i was
expecting to cheer when i said that um
so uh what we get back is string and you
say well why is that the context well
if i'm taking out an it there's only one
place i can take it out so to put a hole
here all i need to do is record the
other string because there's only one
place the hole can be
um
does he talk about the generating
function
i don't think so i don't know maybe i
don't know
i don't really know
a lot
if it's just um
a good thing to investigate i don't
think so i think i think that i think
that you'll see that there would
probably be some more difference
that's a word that mathematicians like
to use right when like radiates okay
i think as long as you stick to
something that's um
in some categorical sense finally
generated you're probably fine because
we're actually playing pretty fast and
loose with a lot of isomorphisms here
specifically one time string is string
that's not string it's it's uh it's
uniquely isomorphic to string
and we did that earlier when we took the
derivative of type x relative x
that being one is actually uniquely
isomorphic to one yeah because there's
an x tag in it so we're really just
doing uh counting procedures and finance
set if you want in which case you could
apply
yeah i don't
i don't know what these things
so he gets into that basically i think
what he basically says is you know
you'll have to do this at any point in
which you start evaluating it you can't
do it like odd for your eye and just
make it you're sure you have it right so
at the point of binding right i'll just
keep doing it internally but what we'll
do we'll see in a second is in chances
where we can have these x's nested into
other types um how we can resolve that
um but i think in in general in that
case you're supposed to kind of assume
that that y is like a base there's
nothing inside there's no other types
inside of that
except like you know yeah disruption is
one other thing but yeah i agree with
you that was the thing i thought about
but like i didn't know enough to
actually resolve so anyway um so how do
i take that derivatives of definitions
uh well they're a little bit of a
problem because and this is kind of what
you're talking about a little bit but a
context for x could either be at the
base level of f and which we're fine
right or it could be inside of the the s
type that we're substituting in for so
we can't just take the partial
derivative of f because uh we have extra
information so um as he says it's really
simple all you have to do is apply the
multi-variable chain rule and the
special case in which uh the the first
and the first function applied to the
first argument is the end
no yeah actually that's making sense um
i mean it does but i don't want to
really get into it um so um what he
eventually says is he says the the
partial derivative of definition we find
x's remember we're going to talk about
this in intuitive sense right we find
x's in fs where y is defined to be s by
either finding them at the top level of
the f structure right so maybe it's like
the the we're looking for an and it's
it's glued on right at the top level of
the structure it doesn't even matter
what y is we don't even care about that
or
or we have to pick out a specific one of
the y's in the top structure and then
look for the x inside of that right and
i'll show you some examples of what that
means in a second but um
i think i think it makes more sense so
basically you're either look if you're
looking for x's and f where y equals s
either your x is at the top level of f
and you don't care about what's in the y
or your x is inside of the y and then
you have to record which way and find it
inside of that this is kind of what we
do with the tree right where we said
either we're already at the level where
we're looking for our hole or we have to
say which way we went left or right and
then find our hole inside of that okay
so you know uh here's the def here's an
example here say i have these this
parametric type foo y um where it's a
pair of string and whatever y is right
and i'm defining y the integer right i
want to find an int context okay that's
great so either right it i have my
context already here which i don't and
that will reduce the zero or i have it
inside of the y which i do in which case
it will be it will reduce to one times
string and then we have the string type
like we saw earlier right so either it's
already here which is not um but it
could be or it's inside of that y in
which case we will
write down it's like environmental
information and go deeper which is
exactly what we do when we
choose strength so let's take a quick
breather um
there's a lot to get through um and we
still have recursive derivatives to get
through so
all right okay so now how do we how do
we uh how do we take the derivative of a
recursive type right we haven't really
dealt on the deal with that yet so what
he says is well first let's let's expand
the recursive type into a definition
we'll say the type is f right and then
we'll define all x's in that type to be
the fixed point of f with respect to x
okay that's fine that makes sense but
you basically you know that's that's the
definition of like recursion in a sense
right so okay that makes sense and then
basically he just applies the definition
rule that we saw
back here right does the same thing so
what we look for here is we say well
either you find your ex at the top level
right or you have to you have to find it
one level deeper and you have to record
which choice you made to get there this
again either you find at the top level
of the tree or you record left or right
and then you look for it one level
deeper but do you see why this doesn't
help us this specific definition because
right here is the thing we were trying
to find in the first place right so
we've just kind of postponed our problem
so what this is what we need in the
first place oh no
okay so he says like in like one like
amazing like sentence like
clearly this is isomorphic to this um
and if we really wanted to which oh i'm
sorry
and intuitively it actually makes sense
why the two would be isomorphic right
because at every level we're either
taking the level we're at or digging
deeper into it we can kind of think of
that what else what else is either stops
or goes one level deeper into the
thinking itself
it's a list right that's the description
of a list either we are an empty type of
a list right or we we you know have a
head constant to a tail right so so what
he says is and and again this does make
sense if you really stare at it long
enough until like your eyes cross and
what he says is what we can do is we can
just represent this kind of thing right
here
this lap going deeper as a list of
deeper taken steps does that kind of
make sense in the uh oh sorry
sorry can you just i may have missed
this where did life
oh so why is in this in this uh example
um the uh where did i
why from uh why came from the philosophy
spelling error somewhere
oh no
he's the the y just represents one of
the uh one of the like container types
um so uh so what he says is if you're
just continually going down a list down
this down steps maybe it's at the top
right in which this case this list would
be empty and then you could just record
the context right here or maybe you have
to take a bunch of steps down so i'll
record all those steps and then once i
get to the level where i find my x then
i can just you know i can just say where
the x was at that level so it kind of
makes sense why these two are in fact in
the paper he doesn't show how he derives
that unless he had a stroke of genius i
don't know if there's some math rule
that he applied that he
fails to share with us i don't know if
i'm just real dumb but um he basically
says oh this is isomorphic this
obviously um
because it's a list of steps until you
get to your holds level and then the
context of that level but i think that
kind of makes sense actually because
we've seen that with zippers already and
we know that if we have a recursive type
we just peel away the levels until we
get to the level we want to be at and
that's the list action and then we get
there and we show where at that level
that thing is so that's cool and i don't
think this slide actually is very useful
i i may have this like little h2 where
it's like oh we kind of are encoding a
sum with a list are we factoring by some
oh no it's not
um so we have this type right a list of
steps until you get to your holes level
then it's context at a level well where
have we heard of those things well flash
back to a long time ago like 15 minutes
ago right we this is exactly what the
zipper was a list of steps path right we
choose left or right record when we pass
by and then we eventually get to the
level that our thing is at so this we
found
he found this is the zipper type right
so it seems like we're on the right
we're on the right track so let's just
let's just test this out so
time to do a little you know mechanical
stuff so what's the one whole context of
the list well let's write the list type
okay a list of x's right is either an
empty list cool or the product of an x
and another list so the head and the
tail
does that make sense right we've all
seen this before a lot of us have
probably seen this before cool
does that make sense
so cool so then you know or we could
just write this as uh you know this
whole thing is
right and remember i said read this as
i'll substitute this whole thing for the
y in here
which is basically the same thing this
is way clearer but say i couldn't
actually call it list
then i would write it like that so
i don't actually want to really go
through the steps with you because i
think that it's not very interesting it
just it works and then eventually what
you get is you get lists of product of
lists and lists now does this make sense
does it make sense to say that a hole in
a list is a product of two lists why
does that make sense anyone want to
shout it out
exactly
it's the prefix and the suffix it's
worth pointing out the list that comes
before it all the pointers are pointing
to the left like they're pointing the
opposite way they're pointing away from
the hole sure sure absolutely i mean the
way that we'd have to write some kind of
operation we actually wanted to write
something kind of algorithm on this like
list zipper which i've heard people call
it is you have to assume that like tail
operations and head operations are equal
costs or something like that which you
know why not and the first the
foreign
absolutely and you're gonna hit the tail
or the for the head
empty list the whole and then the rest
of the list exactly so if our hole was
at one instead of that two then we would
have the product of the empty list and
then two three four
so
point so does that mean um the prefix
would be written backwards
no like if the hole was at three it
would be list one two yeah yeah it would
be list one two and then four okay i was
just saying that if you actually wanted
to write some kind of algorithm that
operates on that to like zip it back and
forth you'd have to say like to move one
to the left you would take the tail make
that the new hole the you know the new
hole or just rather yeah and then you're
really with a pair of singly linked
lists then the prefix would be a reverse
list
okay so would be reversed
i think i can verify if you were
actually implementing it manually it
would be that the way that connor
derives it it is not that right okay
it's just plain inefficient and also
yeah i mean we don't implement things
if we can write their type signatures
the program is written right
no okay so then um and then you can do
the exact same thing for the context for
binary tree back to that oh sorry yeah
i'm sorry that was fun oh yeah so
basically just again just to sum up if
we wanted to find like a hole in the
list we would choose which thing we're
taking out in this case four right so
you know intuitively we'd write it like
this and then we just record the prefix
and the suffix and then again
i know i'm hammering home on this but um
if you actually want to make it a full
zipper you'd have to you know pair this
whole thing with the value that we
deleted it would be four little bits one
two three and five exactly
and then again this just proves that it
works for the binary tree as well
like looking at it now i'm just like i
don't want to go through this step by
step it seems like a total drag but what
you ultimately get is you know you apply
the rules to the fixed point you apply
the rules for definition um
you simplify it and then ultimately what
you get to is you say okay the context
type for uh the one whole context type
rather for a binary tree is a triple of
a list of steps you have to take either
left right the value you passed and the
other tree that you're not carrying that
you don't care about as well as the
children of wherever your hole is and
this is what we went over right in the
beginning so
at the very least i'm glad we're back to
where we started from
so does the big idea make sense now
first of all i should say that i googled
newton live in his fan art not knowing
what i was expecting and
i found a lot of it
like there are like sympathizers that
are like oh that jerk newton i've been
pushed around my whole life so i know
how long this feels like
i do not expect to read the sentence i
know how loud this feels
but so just the big idea makes sense now
here's where it's like the heady like i
don't know if any of this makes sense
and then someone's like oh there's a
full more reason this probably does make
sense
um uh which i don't know but so
basically in calculus right a derivative
describes the relationship between
instantaneous rates of change right and
you can think of context kind of like
that as well right so you know if and
granted i'm playing real fast to lose
here so no one try to like formalize
what i'm saying at all or even checking
for accuracy but like
you know if like if you take like you
know if you have a function right and
then you graph its derivative basically
what you're graphing is right the rates
have changed at every point of that
function but it kind of is remember how
we use that phrase like a glove turned
into a return glove turned inside out um
it's kind of like that because it like
looks backwards and looks forwards it
says what do i mean in terms of my you
know everything around me and the
interesting thing and this is the only
part that i'm comfort confident with
talking about is this actually similar
to leibniz's um theory of omniscience or
knowledge in the world in which he has
this really famous line where he talks
in the methodology where he says yeah
motivology full circle cool
where he taught he says if somebody knew
one thing perfectly say you knew it's
spatial resolution perfect positioned
perfectly in the world that would entail
knowing its facial position in
relationship to everything else in the
world right um therefore you know
everything in the world so to know any
one thing is know everything this is
kind of the backbone of the idea of what
a moana is but it shows the same kind of
glove turned inside out kind of
relationship which is if we look at
something hard enough if we can
completely characterize its relationship
to everything else in the universe we're
talking about say a point on a function
or say a context in a type we actually
have enough information to talk about
that type or to talk about the the rest
of its function which i think is kind of
cool that like it wasn't that he had a
philosophy and i'm not saying everyone
caught this but he had a philosophy and
then he tacked on some math or something
like that it was actually these two
ideas fed each other in a pretty
interesting way um so why should you
care and now
you're probably not gonna be asked to
implement a zipper tomorrow um i really
doubt it i'd be super surprised i'm sure
someone's like uh actually my company
makes professional zippers
we're an industrial zipper shop all in a
cloud
that's not important but it demonstrates
kind of this value of
the ability to transform between types
because now we've shown a way we can
mechanically derive one type that has a
special relationship to another one
namely the context from the type of
which is the context which means that if
we had some kind of language that in
which we could write functions on types
and get other types out then basically
we could write functions in terms of
types and get for free because again if
you can write the type of signature
you've already written the program um
but you get for free the function that
operates on its context so in this super
magical world where we have this
language that just works perfectly like
this what we can kind of do is we can
meta program context we can say we get
zippers for free as long as we've
defined correctly that all whatever type
we want that to zip over and that's kind
of neat right because you can start to
see where if we can start thinking like
that if we can start
if we improve these kind of mechanical
relationships between types once we can
express those in programming languages
then we can stop having to write the
boilerplate i guess all programs become
boilerplate at some point right
the idea is nothing unique but um
you wouldn't have to even write the
thing where you say okay now here's the
function that transforms it into its
context here's the function that
operates on its context and here's the
function that puts it back you would
just write these type generic functions
that operate on types and then
the your it could handle all the rest um
uh yeah so that's cool um
so how do you do this well you need a
language which types of just values just
values that you can operate on normally
because you need to be a hey what's
that up
look at that we're i mean we are we are
innovating in real time i mean that
makes sense he even mentions like in the
paper he's like there's some haskell
stuff for this doesn't kind of work all
the way but it's promising and i'm
working on a thing that's promising
there's a lot of promising things uh
so then you've read a context function
that transforms types into their
one-world context types and then if you
can write type generic functions you can
automatically trans um form functions
that from type t or function that's on
keys context and i wrote an example of
this in idris
that i i probably
don't really have time to actually go
through um but i can show you basically
what it looks like what the output looks
like real quick right so say i have this
thing called test tuple right and i
define this just in my uh
oh oh my goodness look who's finding
more can it handle it
thanks sorry there we go it's the blue
yeah sorry so this so basically it i had
to rewrite the types of it because the
reflection and address is a little wonky
or at least i don't understand it or
it's too complicated or all these things
but so i over here i define a uh
oh my goodness can i thread this needle
there we go okay sorry to find a test
star this is really going to use polona
uh it doesn't really matter test two
bullets there's a tubal of one two three
four one two three four right a
quadruple i think that's the word triple
who knows um so anyway so i have this
one two three four thing right it was
the thing that we were kind of looking
at before and its type right here right
is integer to the fourth right ref power
now i thought that was like sound and
mathematical right times uh its type is
left power i4 right so i was actually
able to write an address a function
called context that operates on this
type and produces another type rather
type of context which allowed me to
actually write a type save function that
says i can take any tuple a one two or
three tuple twelve tuple right and spit
out the contextual type for that which
would at least be difficult if you
didn't have something like this and
that's all it does as far as i got but
so i can actually write okay put a hole
in the place of two in this tuple and
when we get back out is okay so this is
how you write uh the number two
in address um
don't worry about why um
it's the way that you can ensure that
number you pass into a function shorter
than your vector so that it will be
safely operated on it won't go out of
index anyway so you say okay we have a
hole at position two that represents
that like you know left right or left
middle right or something like that
right these are the numbers that remain
right and then its type here right is
this is cool product of four and i to
the third
so you can actually kind of do it right
it actually works right i mean i only
did it for tuples because you know i got
things to do
but it actually does work and it
actually is possible to to do to at
least a certain extent
in the address that's cool so and then
finally i'm closing this note
he says this really kind of empowering
thing at the end where he's like i don't
know if this be used for anything i
don't even really know why it works i
kind of have some intuitions that's why
it works and i don't know if it's useful
right but the cool thing is one only
happens to open one's old school
textbooks you know which we all use as
children um almost at random and ask
what does this mean for data types and
like this idea was kind of inspiring to
me because it made me think of well if
you can take the derivative of these
algebraic data types what else can you
do or what do laws that i know and say
algebra mean when translated to types
you know i mean some of this stuff might
not mean anything right then some of it
might not be a translation for some of
it these assumptions that we're making
like you mentioned to allow us to kind
of play fast and loose might be violated
and then you know they no longer work um
but it's it's inspiring that this kind
of vector of thought is there that we
can kind of attack um you know just
exploration of the space on this kind of
level and that's the thing that makes me
love this paper it's that this paper you
know kind of inspired me to say well
what if i take something that i
understand at least decently like types
apply something that i've totally
forgotten about like calculus and
combine the two and and you know kind of
interrogate their results so that's uh
that's drtohc
he talks about this right he says i
don't know what integration would mean i
i mean i think he should also i don't
know what
uh division would mean uh because i i
don't really know
there might be an answer to that yeah
there's a really cool neighborhood you
like this oh yeah
uh like outbreak types in the like the
field of rationals okay so they define
what negative and fractional types
logic variables and continuations oh
what is that what's the division what is
a fraction i think negative types are
continuations okay types that expect
other types
and fractionals are like so like if i
have like one over a list that means i
have like
like
i have like partial information about
whether or not i know something about
the list oh that's cool
i don't know exactly
one thing
which is just an exponential i didn't i
don't think he did either
you can totally take the derivative
so uh right right so what would that
mean would what would a function be well
i guess a function would just be a
parametric type or something like that
so algebraic we have the function type a
arrow b right
raised to the 8th power right so okay i
see what you're saying oh yeah that is
really awesome yeah i mean you think
about that the tony is true though like
you know oh cool
so how's that really it's like oleg
general zippers like the generic ones
like the ones that i have no
uh clothes
they just work for any type of libraries
oh
don't look at all this stuff because
you'll just get trolled by friends code
what a god
that's cool i bet you could you could
because all you need to have from going
up down left and right
and if you can actually if you actually
have the generics reflected so that you
can see that structure you're good and
then if you combine that with being able
to like calculate the proof of types
you don't even have to write any code
ever again
very cool at least if you're working for
a zipper shop you know
professional
big zip you know
enterprise zippers
i like to think i like to think of this
guys i want the best
this guy's an enterprise zipper right
here
that's
yeah no so it's it's it's kind of like
um
like well
they can't have religious beliefs
they're kind of like people kind of like
corporations
they're sheeps
yeah they're uh tetris it's all tetris
they're ender funkers
i love that word
anything else oh how do you deal with
multi-hole context
um yeah that's that's a that's a cool i
thought that i had it's like what if you
wanted to pick out two holes and i bet
what you could do is you could pick out
both holes independently of each other
and then have the product of those two
holes i think that would probably be a
fine like oakley
how do you store it in a flat list if
you have to store the context for both
folders like so there's there are
actually multiple different versions for
multiple contexts and then correspond to
different types of uh
of consistency guarantees like green
committed right committee like
transactional
properties
i don't know how to say his last names
website
just basically dedicate two or three
months to reading this ftp
that's interesting so it would be like
like a like whatever
couldn't you just keep applying it
like store the context for the first
hole go down right right context within
that right that that which is indeed how
we find
you know
zipper file system
exists i don't know it really exists
it's really up there
it seems to be the main thing that
people use zippers for like if you
google like what our zippers use for
like the answers you always find are the
zipper file system and uh x mona
actually
no no lens talk not allowed to talk
about lenses right now
save that stuff for the bar
yeah and i believe i haven't looked at
source but apparently that's how
everyone learned haskell
except me but
i believe that it uses zippers to manage
like parenthood of windows
that's cool
do you have a question
again a generating function saying it's
very natural why the derivative should
be the
one whole context because the
combinatorics
the derivative is
is of the generating function of objects
of points then it's a generating
function for objects in length n minus
one
where uh you get the second kind of
object by pointing out one of the things
in the first object is there a paper
that or like a text we could look at to
learn more
functionology
yeah i'm sorry
the first chapter is awesome
for those of you who use that
parentheses
chapter
one exclamation point that shows that
that's the best one i think there's a
coursera course that says yeah by the
way author robert targen
yes or no
sarah
course by who
robert hardin
t-a-r-j-n oh yeah
information effects
and uh computing in the field of
rationals
this is awesome
information effects and are these both
oleg no those are both some indiana guys
plus
you have to oh i think we're like there
but so you have to read information
effects it really makes sense to the
second one but the first one's cool too
it's about uh treating forgetting things
as a side effect
is that the honor of savory though yeah
savory that's what it is cool yeah
and and one one thing i'd also add is in
this in this uh in this paper um
connor references or professor mcbride
um
references
a paper that his father wrote about like
involving pattern matching and and
derivatives and all that kind of cool
stuff and i would actually recommend uh
it's actually hosted somewhere on on
professor mcbride's website but um it
actually you can there's a really neat
chapter in there about how you can use
pattern matching to calculate
derivatives and it's really cool i found
it to be a very interesting read
regarding the direct relationship
between
these derivatives and actual derivatives
of calculus functions so what you're
saying about
generating functions is that if you have
this algebraic data type thing you take
this
the initial algebra associated to it
this is some sort of set of trees and
then you create a generating function on
the set of trees okay and then
uh the zipper actually does go into the
vertical equation
oh cool that's the theory of species
that's awesome that's why i love this
meetup right this is crazy
i like i have like three things fourth
thing a lot of homework
my girlfriend's out of town tonight so i
know
we have a question i was wondering um
you said it works only for regular types
just that uh mean that it doesn't work
for a generalized graph
is it related to the context-free kind
of structure
you know i i can't really i don't really
know i can't speak that i think that i
don't know i think that anything that
you could he means anything you can
express giving given just you know like
the you know the unit types the empty
type
sums products uh recursive types
definitions and weakenings um anything
you can express with those tools it
works for
anything that looks like a power series
yeah
necessarily
that you look at if you just want to
have some more fun is it he also shows
how
um
the derivative of the list type uh look
at the part where he shows he's like as
a fun side note look at how this also
looks at like you know the summation
series of like uh of uh of uh um
i'm blatant on the word can someone help
me
i need i need a paper
uh
it's actually a much clearer way to
figure out why they'll how to take the
derivative of the list that he says i'm
using he actually uses the word
amusingly um oh yeah he said amusingly
the following power series represents
list x which is one plus x plus x
squared plus x cubed
oh so that is the connection that we
were getting at
i should have put that one i should have
put that slide in there
yeah so that's that's on page seven so
if you want to kind of get a sense of
what i believe this is similar where
you're wrong though right
so maybe it's not amusing at all maybe
it's very profoundly uh how the
following power series represents list x
although it should be noted that not all
of these things are equal if you like
mod out by
equivalence right certain
representations of risk of lists are
much more useful than others right like
one plus x plus x squared plus x cubed
is not a lot useful if i want to write a
recursive math function
yes
yeah
like i said
my caveat was you know caveat is that
like
you know
he introduces a lot of like formalism to
make kind of like cover his bases that i
like left out to make it like a little
you know more
shady
is that it
all right well thanks thanks everybody